[Music]
We see the Venn diagram of two sets in the
previous video Set of people who like soccer
A D & G and Set of people who like
cricket B C D & G Looking at the
sets could you write The set of people like soccer
And Cricket This Means That We Have Been
Asked For The Set Of People Who Like At Least
One Of The Ports We Have To Find S Y C Which
Actually Means S And C And Both A D
And G Like Soccer Looking At The Cricket Set
D And  What is
the set of people who like soccer and
cricket we have to
find  s
Intersection C Which is the Set of People Who
Like Both Soccer and Cricket There Are
Just Too Many People Who Like Both the Sports D
and G But We Have Already Seen All This Before How
is the Venn Diagram Helping Us Let's
Zoom Out and Look at  The Beauty of V
Diagrams This is set s with ad and g and this
is set c with d g b and c We can see that
d and g are common to both the sets so let's
move set c to the left so that they
overlap  Since they have a few
elements common to each of them and yes they are called
overlapping
sets now we need to see how it helps us find s or s it is simple
you just write all the
elements you see here edges
b and s thats the advantage  Of using
one diagrams well it directly gives as
a representation of all the elements in
consideration and what about s intersection
C This is much simpler we just write the
elements in the overlapping region D and G This means that once we
draw the one diagrams
correctly union  And the intersection can be found
out with in a few seconds
[music]